es tiempo de elecciones y tenemos al
candidato a contra el candidato b y nos
interesa saber cuál es la probabilidad
de que el candidato a gane la elección
lo ideal sería encuestar a toda la
población de votantes digamos que hay
100.000 personas en esta población y
preguntamos a cada persona quién es su
candidato favorito con esta información
podemos encontrar la proporción de la
población que apoya al candidato a pero
esto no es realista pues no podemos
entrevistar a todas las 100.000 personas
así que en lugar de esto vamos a hacer
lo que generalmente hacemos en
estadística muestra mos la población y
calculamos el estadístico para cada
muestra para poder estimar este
parámetro digamos que tomamos una
muestra de 100 personas y calculamos la
proporción muestral de los que apoyan al
candidato a digamos que de estas 100
personas 54 dicen que apoyan al
candidato a así que aquí la proporción
muestral es 0.54 aquí tenemos que darnos
cuenta de que no siempre tendremos este
0.54 si tomamos otra muestra de 100
personas podremos tener una proporción
muestral diferente
en esta ocasión en la proporción
muestral es igual a 0.58 en estadística
ya contamos con herramientas que nos
permiten darnos cuenta de cuál puede ser
la distribución de las proporciones
muestrales que podemos obtener tenemos
la distribución muestral de la
proporción muestral para b igual a 100
podemos describir las posibles
proporciones muestrales que podemos
tener y sus probabilidades con esta
distribución muestral debido a que el
tamaño de la muestra es mucho más
pequeño que el tamaño de la población es
menor que el 10% podemos suponer que
cada persona que es entrevistada es una
ejecución más o menos independiente y
también si suponemos que la proporción
verdadera no es muy cercana a cero o muy
cercana a 1 podemos decir que la
distribución muestral es aproximadamente
una curva normal conocemos muchas cosas
sobre la distribución muestral de
proporciones muestrales si esto no les
parece conocido los invito a que vean
los vídeos que tenemos en caná khadem y
sobre este tema
sabemos que la media de esta
distribución muestra va a ser la
proporción verdadera de la población y
también conocemos la desviación estándar
de esta distribución ésta
una desviación estándar estas son dos
desviaciones estándar y aquí tenemos
tres desviaciones estándar por arriba de
la media aquí hay una desviación
estándar aquí hay dos desviaciones
estándar y tres desviaciones estándar
por debajo de la media
esta es la desviación estándar de la
proporción muestral para esta
distribución muestral ya vimos esta
fórmula con anterioridad es la raíz
cuadrada de pep por 1 - p donde p es la
proporción de la población dividida
entre el tamaño de la población es por
eso que esto es específico para n igual
a ciento vamos a enfocarnos en este
primer escenario cuando tenemos una
muestra de tamaño 100 y tenemos la
proporción muestral de 0.54 podemos
tener muchos resultados aquí quizás 0.54
se encuentre aquí o quizá este valor se
encuentre aquí y la razón de esta
incertidumbre es que no conocemos cuál
es el parámetro verdadero de la
población veamos una cuestión un poco
más sencilla cuál es la probabilidad de
que la proporción muestral de 0.54 se
encuentre dentro de dos desviaciones
estándar de p pausa en el vídeo y traten
de responder a esta pregunta
es como decir que si vamos a tomar una
muestra y vamos a calcular la proporción
muestral cuál es la probabilidad de que
se encuentre dentro de dos desviaciones
estándar alejada de la media es esta
área de acá sabemos que al estudiar
curvas normales aproximadamente el 95%
del área se encuentra entre estas dos
decisiones estándar así que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 95% 95% de las
veces que tenga una muestra de tamaño
100 y encuentre esta proporción muestral
ésta se ubicará dentro de estas dos
desviaciones estándar pero si tomamos
este enunciado podemos crear un nuevo
enunciado podemos decir que hay una
probabilidad del 95% de que p se
encuentre en dos desviaciones estándar
de p con sombrero que es igual a cero
punto 54 pausa en el vídeo y vean que
estos dos enunciados son equivalentes
hay una probabilidad del 95% de que la
proporción muestral se encuentra dentro
del área de dos desviaciones estándar de
la proporción verdadera y esto es
equivalente a decir que hay una
probabilidad del 95% de que
proporción verdadera se encuentre en dos
desviaciones estándar de nuestra
proporción muestral esto es muy
interesante ya que si podemos encontrar
este valor podemos calcular lo que se
llama un intervalo de confianza y quizá
encuentren un problema aquí ya que para
poder calcular esto la desviación
estándar de esta distribución debemos
conocer el parámetro de la población
pausa en el vídeo y piensen que
podríamos hacer en lugar de esto si no
conocemos el valor de p si no conocemos
la proporción de la población existe
algo que podamos usar en su lugar como
un estimado de la proporción de la
población cielo hay ya calculamos p con
sombrero que es la proporción muestral
por lo que podemos definir un nuevo
estadístico que es el error estándar el
error estándar de la proporción muestral
y lo definimos como ya que no conocemos
la proporción de la población vamos a
usar la proporción muestral es la raíz
cuadrada de peso hombro por 1 - p
sombrero entre n en este caso sabemos
que n es igual a 100 y resulta que
aunque no vamos a demostrarlo en este
vídeo este es un estimador in sesgado de
esto de acá
es igual 0.54 por 1 - 0.54 que es 0.46
entre 100 sacamos la calculadora para
encontrar la respuesta es la raíz
cuadrada de 0.54 x 0.46 entre 100 y nos
da 0.49 que vamos a redondear a la
milésima más cercana y nos queda 0.05
esto es aproximadamente igual a 0.05
otra forma de expresar esto es que
aunque no lo conocemos ahora tenemos un
estimado por lo que ahora podemos decir
que confiamos en que hay una
probabilidad del 95% de que p que es el
parámetro verdadero que queremos
calcular se encuentre en dos errores
estándar de la proporción muestral que
tenemos y que es dos veces el error
estándar el error estándar es igual a
0.05 y si lo multiplicamos por 2 nos da
0.1 esto está muy bien porque podemos
decir que confiamos en que hay una
probabilidad del 95% de que el parámetro
verdadero se encuentre en el intervalo d
si está una décima por debajo de la
proporción muestral que calculamos será
0.44 hasta una décima más de la
proporción muestral que calculamos así
llega a 0.64 esto es interesante porque
acabamos de establecer que este
intervalo de aquí es algo llamado
intervalo de confianza y el nivel de
confianza para este intervalo es 95% en
el futuro podemos ajustar esta
probabilidad pero el 95% es lo que la
gente usa típicamente una idea
relacionada que pueden escuchar seguido
es la noción de margen de error y
podemos verlo como la mitad de la
longitud de este intervalo de confianza
o el radio del intervalo de confianza si
este intervalo va de 0.54 menos el doble
del error estándar 0.1 a 0.50 y 4 más el
doble del error estándar 0.1 en este
caso lo que está por arriba y por abajo
de nuestro estimado es el margen de
error el margen de error en este caso es
0.1 pueden ver que este concepto se
menciona en periódicos
mencionan encuestas en donde encuestaron
a 100 personas y encuentran que el 54%
de esas personas dicen apoyar al
candidato y hay un margen de error del
10% en este escenario quizás se
pregunten cómo podemos disminuir este
margen de error y para hacerlo debemos
disminuir esto de acá y cuál es la mejor
manera de reducir esto pues aumentando
el denominador de aquí así que lo que
vemos generalmente es que mientras más
grande sea el tamaño de la muestra
tendremos un margen de error más pequeño
o un intervalo de confianza más compacto
nos vemos en otro vídeo